I grew up in the suburbs of New York.
I was very fortunate in that I had a
really good public education and that
public education actually led me to the
Rockefeller when I was 16.
I was passionate about biology and the
Rockefeller has a series which they
still have of lectures called the
holiday lectures,
which are lectures for high school
students right after Christmas and now I
guess there's a whole sort of internet
way of getting the tickets if you're
interested.
But then that wasn't.
The Internet didn't exist so the.
The way that they were distributed with
each high school in the area got to and
so they were quite quite a valuable
commodity at my high school among the
students who were interested and I was
given one and so I guess it was in 1976
in December.
I had the great fortune of hearing
Christian to do speak about the cell and
he gave this amazing tour of the
interior of the stem cell,
which I could probably sit here and
spend about an hour telling you about.
Which is kind of amazing because it was
so long ago.
But it was a brilliant lecture and in
fact the lecture is referred to in a
book that he wrote called vital dust,
which is also a wonderful book,
but I was just inspired and I,
I,
at that moment,
I knew that this was what I wanted to
do,
what he didn't know what that moment
was.
That was the place that I was getting
ended up doing it.
I didn't ever dream that I would be that
fortunate and I,
through a series of coincidence,
coincidence,
I got a summer job with a young
investigator at the time who was
studying dendritic cells,
which was something nobody had ever
heard of because he had discovered them.
This was 1976 and Ralph Steinman,
who was my mentor then in my mentor now
discover dendritic cells in 1971 or 72.
The first publications were Njm,
the Journal of experimental medicine in
1973.
So I came into the lab and he had one
technician and he was at the bench and I
was free labor.
So he was in his now rather frugal.
And I learned to work in laboratory with
him,
which was wonderful because shortly
after that,
probably two years after that,
he stopped doing benchwork himself and
he was remarkable in that he'd made an
observation that other people didn't
believe and he had the ability and the
tenacity to stick with that observation.
People thought that the,
the primary antigen presenting cell in
the body or the cell that would show
other cells anything foreign,
which is what an antigen is,
was the macrophage.
And Ralph had discovered dendritic cells
in cultures of macrophages and dendritic
cells are really potent.
You only need like one or are literally,
you need like literally 100.
And so when he saw something,
nobody else believed him.
But Dr Cohen,
who was his mentor did and they were
tenacious and stuck with it.